can we talk about barbers revelation
last year about cloning her dogs yeah
Nancy got to the bottom of that too
my dogs are so adorable I mean to come
home to every night and that three of
them are at the door you know I want to
know about the cloning I was so devoted
to my 14 year old dog Samantha I mean
she was really like my daughter she was
a an oddball that's why I related to her
I was kind of an oddball the only other
way I could get another was to clone her
Wow and it was nothing I mean we had to
put her to sleep it was devastating and
the doctor has to get a special kit yeah
to just get a few cells from the inside
of her cheek and her little tummy on the
outside two of Barbara's three pups are
clones of her beloved Samantha the third
is a rescue she admits her furry little
family is a little spoiled but she
wouldn't have it any other way
there they are so funny the three of
them line up on I say okay everybody sit
because I'm gonna give them a treat yeah
you know and it's the funniest things
how cute is that these dogs give you
unconditional love unconditional love is
something Barbara has gotten a lot of in
her 50 plus year career in fact you had
a special message for her from one
famous fan so I got to play this thing
for you okay boo what Barbara you know I
love you deep is that Deborah yeah Oh
Deborah message so sweet I think that it
would be amazing for you to come and
play my aunt what what are you doing
honey
what what is this a television show
Brian Murphy asked me to be in a series
do know I don't I don't particularly
want to act I don't want to act in our I
just want to direct and you're not
waiting the Ryan Murphy Netflix series
no no I just how about one episode of
Will and Grace not trying to make a deal
here I have to read the script I mean
maybe a walk-on say hello that's a match
she didn't say that right she did not
say no
[Music]